what's going on you guys it's just about
back-to-school time and it's time to put
your bikinis away that means no longer
bikini season and no longer summer movie
season it is coasting to an end and the
numbers are in we have an intrepid panel
of prognosticators who made their top 10
picks and today we will reveal who had
the quintessential top 10 summer movie
box office lists domestic so let's
reintroduce our panel first you know her
from Rotten Tomatoes oh she's just a
all-around swell gal Jacqueline Kohli
glad to be back
oh good to have you back but it wasn't
weird not to have you back but always
great to have you Jacqueline oh this
lady you know where as the voice of
Moviefone ms Moviefone and she's got the
best fingernails in the biz done on my
nails my nails to eat your face no no no
no no we're gonna need a bigger couch
just kidding this gentleman came all the
way from across the hall you know him
you love him
Mr Dan Morell how's it going how good to
see you dad and a co boy so Before we
jump into what surprised us and what was
pretty much expected regards to the
summer let's take a look at everyone's
lists here's a little memory jogger just
to remind you here's Dan's and here is
gray Drake's list let's see that
Jacqueline Coley list and here's my list
great so all of us picked Toy Story 4
and The Lion King
as one and two
but only two were correct and went to
infinity and beyond with their order dan
and Jacqueline picked them correctly
with Lion King one choice story for
number two yeah I didn't know also that
everyone would not enjoy the movie that
much so either like I think we got the
box-office right but if I was trying to
pick the critic reception of that one I
don't think I would have gotten that
number I really liked it I was yeah I
mean I don't know I haven't seen the
original in a long long time so it was
like oh it felt kind of fresh to me no
it's weird you guys it was weird
I was I was one of those green splats
that I was I was one of them yeah yeah
it doesn't really do it for me I didn't
want to see photorealistic animals
singing songs like it was it was
beautiful to look at but I thought like
I watched and went that was a movie I
have seen previously hey we can all be
happy in the fact that Disney is
laughing their way all the way to the
bank
they own everything including spider-man
far from home partially not anymore
breaking news that was number three and
Dan and gray had that correct so I loved
that Peter Parker in Venice yes to
everyone who said I was wrong about
spider-man I'm right you're right you're
right you're right on the numbers I'm
where I picked it you're right fine you
were the lowest Jackie on having a
spider-man far from home at number five
you were furthest from correct yes that
one so yeah any any thoughts anyone
surprised by a Marvel / Sony film coming
in number 30 I thought that it was a
little bit more forced than homecoming
was yes tone wise they were like trying
to keep up but it ultimately worked out
cuz I thought the plot was really cool I
was really surprised at how it turned
out I was a big fan of it III do think
that the reason that it was so high and
we didn't know this when we made our
picks because I'm so tight into endgame
was how closely they aligned this movie
with Avengers in gaming basically
selling it as a continuation of what
happened in the movie and in some ways
that it was and I think that's what
boosted it up so high both domestically
and worldwide the first spider-man movie
to make a billion dollars worldwide and
also I love anything that said
enters on fabulous accessories by the
way in a superhero movie like yes
amazing not since they live has a movie
so successfully built around a pair of
sunglasses
some glasses other sunglass alright
weekend a birdie yeah gray picked it and
so did I yeah it did not oh that was but
just to be clear I did not make a better
decision I picked the other crappy movie
that should not be on the list being
dark Phoenix so I think we're all gonna
go ahead and put on clown shoes on this
one and just walk our way outside but
why stop there when we remember that I
put Angry Birds - I just panicked and I
poop on down wait a minute didn't kill
the box office but did break the video
game curse I think it's gonna be the
first certified fresh' video game movie
listen it is wetter when when I think
the problem with Angry Birds is so many
people either didn't see the first one
or didn't like the first one and so
that's why they didn't do it I mean we
can't call Angry Birds of video game
movies we're like an app movie there's
the video games of today and yeah back
in my day you sat down on a couch with a
controller in your hand like a phone
video take it easy grandpa rub hogwash
I'll take my lumps I was dead wrong on
minibike international I thought Tessa
Thompson and Chris Hemsworth they would
sell it yeah Jacqueline you were right
that nobody cared any interest in it
whatsoever and by the way it didn't feel
like people making the movie had any
edge no I cannot believe that F Gary
gray directed that movie Oh energies
that have come out since then I don't
think very many people were like they
knew it was a mess before it got there
you know shame
yeah I had a number-10 and no sir yeah
Valkyrie and Thor did not recognize that
magic gray is the only Aladdin hater on
the couch right now and actually I was
relatively surprised my expectations
were so low that I said to my husband I
I wasn't reviewing it and I was seeing
it for myself and I texted him and I
said if it's not good and it's not
getting me I'm coming home halfway
through and I stayed through the whole
movie and came home and he goes Wow so
it was good and I went no I was just
trying to figure it out and that's maybe
you know a billion dollars worth of
people were trying to it's Will Smith
though you know who really made it his
own I thought that it was gorgeous to
look at I thought that Aladdin
relatively forgettable although I can't
wait to see that actor in something else
and really it's all about jasmine yeah a
lady was so great all right so no one
had this on their top 10 list but
placing in the top 10 John wick chapter
3 defied the laws of science neither one
of the first movies together made as
much as that one did that is ridiculous
it just doesn't happen
Keanu is on fire yes both literally and
figuratively
before John wick people would have been
like really now they're like yeah let's
go oh yeah yeah the qiyamah songs yeah
connor east tapped into something just
the site this weird thing this pulse of
of the fans and everything yeah always
be my maybe yeah I mean for John with
chapter 3 a hard-r action movie to
survive like not just in the summer but
like in May in the middle of like the
biggest onslaught like the later part of
the summer kind of spaced out a little
bit like May was just a gauntlet of
movies coming out in May and June and
against all odds that you would think
for John with Chapter three to do as
well as it did surprised the hell out of
me I don't think I don't think it's
often that a movie makes the top ten
that not one single person of before
people that we have in here has put on
their here's a movie that at least one
of us had Dark Phoenix that was
the the Phoenix did not rise it really
did it fell but it wasn't that far off I
will say that it was like 12 or 13 I
just didn't think the movie could be
that bad James McAvoy Jessica Chastain
yeah listen Fassbender was acting the
hell out of that movie I thought he was
doing great I loved every scene that had
that had like sophie Turner and
Fassbender staring at each other so hard
but it didn't amount to much more dour
tone in that film I was pretty joyless I
loved so many so much of the x-men
franchise but this was yeah it's hard to
enjoy Rocket Man I thought you were
gonna make my top 10 list but it did not
yeah yeah just one of those that just
got edged out for like a literal gay
musical fantasy like let's be real it
did it as good as anyone could have
expected
it's impressive like it did reach people
and I that when I saw it I went oh my
god I wonder how people are gonna
respond to this because obviously I love
it but everybody else did too I was
really surprised this is not Queen like
queen is like stadium rock music that
literally goes everywhere Elton John is
popular is amazing it is it's an
acquired taste like you like okay hard
disagree hell you think God is more
ubiquitous than Queen I think the box
office disagrees with like I'm talking
about like in Middle America like I know
they love Freddie Mercury but it's like
they're gonna go to Queen like we will
rock you and I went back and forth
naming I find it like Elton John Hitz
versus Queen hits Elton John's list
would be like yes Queen would be shorter
but which ones if people want to sing
along to and thanks for watching
Jacqueline and how on music did you guys
have any more thoughts anything that
surprised and/or disappointed you about
the summer grey scary stories to tell in
the dark one of my favorite horror
movies of the year how is that movie
pg-13 and so damn spooky I loved it I'll
just say you know I'll pour one out one
more time for book-smart and I'm so glad
that it didn't do
any box office the fact that one's fun
time yes the top ten and also not just
the Quentin Tarantino movie made the
quick top ten but that that one did
because it's so weird yeah long and not
at all mainstream and the fact that it
still found an audience that it that
people were still willing to give it a
shot and go out and see it like
sometimes it would be like that will
come out you're like oh thank god people
will still go see this even if it's not
exactly what they think it might be all
right shall we guy what's to be revealed
yeah okay so let's show the actual list
there it is I think it's up on the
screen if not this part will not be in
the video all right coming in third
place gray Drake with seven out of ten
yes in second place me I guess I didn't
win by an eight out of 10 and we have a
tie for first place which means we had
to go to the tiebreaker Dan and
Jacqueline both had 9 out of 10 we went
to the tiebreaker which was most movies
in the correct order and coming in
second place Dan Merle our winner Jack
[Applause]
I'm sorry I lose every year and I'm
highly competitive how do I win I
thought it wins you can guess the most
in the right spot yes you're the most
right I thought we like just pride yeah
it was Hobson Shah jumping over Pokemon
detective Pikachu you that puts you in
the right placement and so you have the
rock and Jason Statham to think even
when I guess right the rock still screws
me every single year yeah one CIA put
yeah and then I put Baywatch it there by
step make it and then don't come
damn you Dwayne Johnson I know you just
got married but you screwed me how did
you do how many did you get on your list
what were you surprised by this summer
what was like kind of like yeah I
figured that what happened let us know
in the comments section we want to know
I gotta thank this awesome crew of movie
prognosticators Jacqueline Kohli
gray Drake dan Merle well played great
talking with you guys let's do it again
next year how about it again thank you
for watching hit us all up on Twitter
bye bye